[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
oh
[Music]
do you
welcome everyone to meme review boy do
we have a show
for you this evening honor rolling
on the running mr babe time travel is
invented
girls be like yes i can relive the best
moments with my
ex boys be like bro
don't leave your laptop in the hostel
take it with you
also download at least hundred gigabytes
of porn and movies what the
[ __ ] time traveling method girls
boys chief keef you better not lose that
what the
does that mean what if you could be the
opposite gender for one day what would
you do me going to
all the redditors in the world because
otherwise they're all gonna die as
virgins
now that's respect me out for a jog on a
normal day where nothing happened
all right arnold that's cool okay here
we go we got all of them
we got them all boys time travel
invented let's go back to
2010 when things were fine hey romeo
touch again
[Laughter]
don't eat that soup what is that from
why do i not know that reference
hey pizza come on
hey thor go for the head hey touchy nose
hey jfk don't drop the top don't drop
the top my dude
hey dad please
[Music]
it is done it it's done thank you arnold
son
thank you i got the original of this uh
meme
it's hercules in new york from 1969
but it's a classic look at this dude
i want to hear him talk i won't show
them in your olympics in greece how to
do it
did you ai i was what i want to show
them in the olympics in greece
nice one arnold this man became the
governor of california
now that's respect of course he can
travel back in
time of course of course arnold can
travel back in time
time travel is invented everyone else
yes i can meet my past
self me on my way to stop my neighbor
from having sex so his annoying kid is
never born
also me two seconds oh no
[Laughter]
oh no here's the classic time travel
inventor
girls i'm gonna meet my younger self
boys god it won't
about his ass hey felix don't sit on
that wrench you're gonna break your ass
boy
this is the first one i saw this time
travel is invented girls yes blah
boys be like don't go to saint julius
[ __ ] your protest
the roman empire will thrive from
generations
you're a big guy me leaving barnes and
noble after moving all the atheist
authors
to the cringe section you cringe
no one gives a you're real like your
cringe has no power here
me escaping the hospital after refusing
to take my government mandated
you know it's coming run while you came
follow arnold
run across the fields run across the
timelines
oh my god oh what is this doing here do
you ever live
go shoot jin summer
of course oh
of course i
[Music]
all right let's look at the top ones
harambe we have already seen
bully calls me gay me and my boyfriend
about to kick his
ass yeah got him time travel is invented
boys creatures of the creta chaos period
no my fellow creator cares
do not fret dig deep and dig
fast when we can all get out of this i
know it seems tough
but i know you can do it my fellow
creatines
necessitate
[Music]
i gotta review it first i really like
this theme arnold looking hella freaking
fly in that beanie it's funny it's a
little edgy
it's got a good range of flavors i love
it
i love it i give it a i give it a
tambourine kiss
of raiding very nice thanks me
[Music]
all right it continues it continues more
and more we've seen so many different
variations
2020 literally worse yeah
yeah i know or might not even see 1914
we go to war i know and then we go to
war again
yeah i think it's been way harder back
in the day
cringe but now the change is what is it
like
e-girl and wholesome girl would you kill
your best friend for one million dollars
oh my god i would never
i couldn't either love you so man he got
a sandwich
that's hilarious i kissed him we had sex
it was so hot you're so lucky
her knee brushed plasma and holy sh
i am having an erection just thinking
about this
it's funny because it's true a boy i
like just texted me
let him hang for a bit he'll go crazy
over you dude a girl alike isn't
replying what does that mean
it means we are ugly
truth a truth before
after i am so confused by this [ __ ]
meme
girls during art look how bad my drawing
is no
emily is really good boys the senate
will decide your face
i am the senate this is a little cringe
i'm not going live
damn my trains are so slow they arrive
15 minutes late
now girl your trains are faced mine are
very slow they arrive 17 seconds too
late
our trains are slow yes what the f is
this meme it's so bad
i saw a couple that were good i swear
bro you know who else has a nice [ __ ]
okay oh my god my bestie how could you
do something so cruel to someone this
night
you'll always live in my heart queen
stay strong queen bessie's forever
boys f delete my browser history bro
bro just do me one just just i just
replace life
that's got to be part of a life
insurance package right why has no one
developed that yet
like a bracelet they have smart
everything right why don't i have a
bracelet that you just hit
if you're dying just hit it computer
explodes
that'd be sick i want it hey hi
bro yeah we should make a meme about how
epic
and quirky boys are why girls are boring
yeah look how chad we are
oh it was it's tumor girl and tumor boy
before it was real that's actually
brilliant
eerie what the offline your mother is a
very nice woman
thanks bro so is yours online
that's cringe i feel lonely oh my god
please don't be sad i'm your bestie i
will
always be by your side why you look so
sad lo
because i don't share my emotion i'm
afraid to be seen as weak among friends
i know heart crack i felt that
wow what a story shut that
yeah why is this being popular again
what the hell so many versions of it
yes i'm using microsoft 3d paint to look
at the memes
yeah you got problem with that hundred
meters sub take it up with a council b
oh my god we're enemy i'm so cute i'm so
irresistible
one of my hand what the [ __ ] it's time
to go
were we a good meme no he's right no
where
again no no it ain't good it ain't good
i
had hopes for this hey man what up
no big titty golf girlfriend oh isn't
real she isn't real she isn't real ah
hey look this meme actually has funny
commentary oh my god yes
haha cute anime girls i know upload
all right we're done oh you know it's
not gonna be good
you know we you know it ain't good
uh what
is that what i give it a one one
tambourine smack and that's not an
enthusiastic one ma'am your wallet fell
down
i have a boyfriend
then on your wallet i have a boyfriend
you made me do something nice for you
how do you have a boyfriend
do you have a boyfriend yeah well i
guess i will eat your [ __ ] face like
a bloodborne boss battle
huh sorry those are the rules that'll
make the rules be next
meme
greatest meme of all time has coming out
we did it in the intro
i don't know why this is so [ __ ]
popular but i also know exactly why
because it's hella [ __ ] popping
this song is from the yakuza 0. why did
i not play that game it's so awesome
god damn it and the song is just so
catchy but then people start editing
other people to sing it so we have
[Music]
how do they do it oh god it is
of course
[Music]
i'm cancelled season 2 of scared
pewdiepie now
yes
[Music]
markiplier a bit egotistical like that
so i want to see
you beautiful
everyone sing it now you sing it
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody
all right who else is singing it elsa
from frozen scenes back at me
oh god what have we done
you know that bill gates meme i can't
wait to see what people will do with
computers in the future
i'm sorry bill gates
but you're also thinking about buying
tick tock so the jokes is on you you
better be delete that
as soon as you buy it oh god this is is
this all of them compiled
oh giga chad is there
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
ricardo isn't it holy [ __ ] dude
this is huge huge
rewind is going to have this song ah can
we
that's it for this 66 to get to 10.
bakamitai
gets a 10. god damn it we've never seen
that in a long age time
a long ass time thank you for watching
the most esteemed meme review channel
on youtube see you guys next time uh
subscribe
we got face masks check them out
they'll save your life or you can just
scare them away with the tambourine
if anyone comes near you
it works trust me bye-bye
children of nine farts
time to raise what was once forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops await
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean
foreign